SETH LADD: Thanks everybody
for your patience.
Sorry about that, but
luckily these things
reboot fairly fast.
So we're back online.
Welcome to an episode of
Dartisans, our podcast-style
G+ Hangout On Air where we talk
about the Dart project
and the different elements, and
releases, and news, and
team members.
And today we're doing a
community chat with a lot of
the community members who've
been working on different
projects around the open source
community for Dart.
So welcome everyone.
Very happy to see everyone.
We are broadcasting live.
Today in the studio, we have
Lars Tackmann from Denmark,
who has been releasing a lot
of helpful community open
source libraries.
And we'll talk about what
you've been doing.
But let's go around.
Let's start with, on
my left, Adam.
Introduce yourself.
ADAM SMITH: Hey,
my name's Adam.
I like to hack against
Dart and have fun.
I'm not working on anything in
particular, just kind of
absorbing what everyone else is
doing and then modifying,
playing with, patching,
sending back.
And just really inspecting--
playing with everything that
comes out with Dart.
SETH LADD: Great, thanks.
JOHN EVANS: Now Adam,
don't be so modest.
Because you are the guy who
knows about every single patch
that ever comes out with Dart.
You're the first guy out with
it, and that's who we look to
get that great information.
ADAM SMITH: Thank you.
SETH LADD: Chris, why
don't you go next?
CHRIS BUCKETT: Yeah, sure.
So I'm Chris, Chris Buckett.
And I've done a couple of
libraries, the JSONP library
and the JSON Object Library.
And again, I'm not working
on anything
particular at the moment.
Most of the offline,
professional work is writing
the Dart book, Dart in Action,
which does seem to be taking
up an awful lot of my time.
But it's amazing how much the
language has moved on, quite
like the last month.
The mailing list seems to been
going mad with loads of great
ideas the last couple
of weeks.
And I also run the Dartwatch
blog as well.
And been posting community
updates.
I've been trying to keep on top
of what's been going on in
the community, in terms of
libraries that people have
been releasing and so on.
So I think most of the people
here have got libraries up on
the Dartwatch blog.
And it's just great to
see how much activity
there is going on.
SETH LADD: Cool.
And we'll get back to your
book a little bit later.
John, you're next.
JOHN EVANS: Yes, my
name's John Evans.
And I've been working with Dart
I think now for about
nine months.
Really enjoy it.
It's a great platform.
It's developed--
it's come a long way, certainly
since I started
working with it.
So I've been pleased
with that.
I particularly enjoy the
closeness that the community
has with the Dart team
and the amount of--
I won't say influence--
but certainly the amount of
accordance we're given in our
ideas, and how that shapes
the language.
So it's been really a
great time so far.
The project that is really
taking the most of my time is
the Buckshot UI library.
And so I continue to work
on that, try to
put out a good product.
SETH LADD: Awesome.
So we'll chat about
Buckshot, today.
And then, sorry,
John McCutchan.
The other John.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Hello,
everyone.
SETH LADD: Hi.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I'm John
McCutchan and I've been
working with Dart for,
I don't know, three
or four months now.
I've released the Dart Vector
Math library, which is a
GLSL-like vector math
library for Dart.
So I'm mainly interested
in the gaming
aspect of the Dart language.
SETH LADD: Awesome.
And then, Lars, why don't you
talk about some of the
libraries that you've
been working on.
LARS TACKMANN: Yeah, my
name's Lars Tackmann.
I'm doing a start up in Dart.
And so I'm basically just
developing the libraries that
I needed to do that.
Everything from a small working
library to integrating
with Amazon's website, which is
via Phonegap integration.
SETH LADD: Where can we
find these libraries?
LARS TACKMANN: We can
find them on GitHub.
SETH LADD: I think
GitHub, GitHub,
everyone's using GitHub.
Is that right?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
SETH LADD: Yeah?
Awesome.
[INAUDIBLE] fan myself.
I think the Phonegap
one is the most
interesting to me, at least.
Cause I know a lot of start
ups, or just generally
developers, want to
get their apps
across multiple platforms.
What's the experience been like
porting the Phonegap that
most people are familiar
with to something
that Dart can use?
LARS TACKMANN: It's
been pretty good.
There's some weird things when
we got to have to integrate
with JavaScript.
We had to do a call back from
JavaScript into Dart.
But it was pretty quick
to get running.
And there's also a good chance
to make an API that fits more
with the API that Dart
has already.
So I'm looking a lot into
how [INAUDIBLE]
guys are creating the
new APIs and trying
to fit it into that.
So it gets that good platform
feel rather than just doing a
direct port of how the
API is in JavaScript.
SETH LADD: Oh, good.
OK.
So you make it feel Darty
in the process.
Well you mentioned trying to
get data back and forth
between Dart and JavaScript.
So Chris, you mentioned really
briefly your JSONP library.
What was that like trying to get
these two worlds to work?
CHRIS BUCKETT: Yeah, it's
pretty interesting.
The JSON library's--
OK, let me think.
I understand why there's an
issue with the JavaScript and
the Dart virtual machines
talking with each other.
And everything has to go via
this message-passing thing,
which is great because
it shares the same
level as the isolates.
But again it could be annoying
if you're coming to Dart for
the first time, and you think,
Oh, all we do is call-outs to
JavaScript like we do
with [INAUDIBLE]
and I can't.
SETH LADD: The way to get Dart
in JavaScript to work right
now, today at least, is
postMessage, is what I'm hearing.
CHRIS BUCKETT: Absolutely, so
the postMessage story is great
as a starting point.
And I know that there is a story
that you guys are after
to improve the postMessage
scenario, I guess.
SETH LADD: Right.
In fact, I think I just saw the
team mark the issue for
better JS interop as an M1,
which is really, really nice.
It's nice to see that we've
heard their feedback and we're
going to try to help
you migrate slowly,
I think, into Dart.
Right, how do you get 10% Dart?
20% Dart?
30% Dart?
Until your whole app
is now 100% Dart.
So that's great.
[INAUDIBLE] soon.
CHRIS BUCKETT: My feeling is
that part of the issue for
JavaScript developers
especially-- as opposed to
Java and C Sharp developers--
so JavaScript developers have
got their whole heads in the
world of JavaScript.
And they know their favorite
libraries.
UI platforms, and so on.
And they want to see, how could
I take advantage of a
bit of Dart, but still make use
of some of the stuff that
I already know?
SETH LADD: Exactly.
That's one of those
key use cases.
But that brings up a good
question for everybody.
We're all developers.
We have our experience in C
Sharp or Java or whatever.
And that, I think, colors our
expectations or concerns when
we approach development
and web programming.
And so maybe John McCutchan,
can you start with the
experience you've had in your
previous languages and how
that's, I guess, shaped the way
you approached Dart or how
you looked at Dart?
So, in other words, how is it
like coming from non-web
programming into web
programming in
this particular case?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Sure.
So my background is primarily
with C++ programming.
And what attracted me to
Dart over JavaScript
was the type system.
I'm very tied to having a type
system and being warned when
I'm doing something silly
or made a typo or
something like that.
So that was what first pulled
me towards Dart rather than
JavaScript.
And the language itself is so
familiar to someone coming
from a C++ background.
Even the syntax for generic
types, like template types,
coming from C++.
Probably the biggest thing that
I've had to get used to
is the lack of value types.
I'm used to being able to pass
a vector to a function and
then modify the vector inside
of that function--
without side effects.
So that's taken a little
bit of getting used to.
But it's easy to wrap your
head around once you
understand the object
model in Dart.
SETH LADD: So John Evans, you
have a strong .Net, C Sharp
background.
How has that affected the way
you've approached web
programming, specifically
with Dart?
JOHN EVANS: Yeah.
For me it was probably the
biggest attractant
coming from the .Net.
And I was really working a lot
in Silverlight at the time and
trying to model web UI
frameworks in that sandbox.
And so stepping in from that
sort of class method
architecture to Dart
was seamless.
It really was seamless
just getting to know
Dart-specific APIs.
And then once you pick that up,
you're off to the races.
I think that was the biggest
pull for me.
And so I really enjoy that
part of the experience.
I think that Dart probably has
its biggest challenge in terms
of sell with the JavaScript
community.
Because their model with the
prototypes is wholly different
from the way you think about
programming standpoint.
But for me, yeah.
It was an easy transition.
SETH LADD: Well, this might be
a good segue into moving from
just language into libraries,
which is why everyone's here
today to chat about their
particular projects.
So I know John you're
working with a
library you call Buckshot.
Tell us more about that.
And I believe it's highly
influenced by .Net or C Sharp
libraries that you're used
to, is that right?
JOHN EVANS: Yeah, it's actually
heavily influenced by
the WPF framework.
Not to be redundant, but WPF--
and Buckshot, by the way, I
called it Buckshot because the
definition in Dart parlance
means that your just throwing
darts all over the board.
So that really inspired
the name there.
So I really enjoyed the
experience in Silverlight and
WPF of having static
templates in XAML.
And then having a strong
data-body model between the
template and code, where you
could bind events and bind
properties and bind primitives,
just literals like
integers, and strings,
and so on.
So my experiment with Buckshot
was really to try to emulate
that model in Dart.
And so over the last eight
months or so, I think I've
gotten to a pretty good
place with that.
I've got templates and a pretty
good binding model.
I don't have events hooked up
yet, still waiting for Dart's
reflection to come
in for that.
But by and large it's been
a pretty good experiment.
I think it shows the
power of Dart.
Because this is certainly a
non-trivial project that I'm
working on.
It's exercised the language
pretty much in every corner,
at least on the client side,
that I can push it.
And it's done pretty well.
So I've been very pleased with
that experience so far.
SETH LADD: How can people
try out Buckshot?
JOHN EVANS: Yeah.
You can just go to the
project on GitHub.
Give it a download.
There's plenty of
documentation.
I got a bunch of videos I've
done that walk you through
different approaches to how to
set up programs with it.
And just give it a try.
Give me some feedback.
I will say, as just a caveat,
that it currently only works
with Dartium and the latest
builds of Chromium.
And that's because I'm using the
latest HTML5, CSS3 APIs--
the very latest--
to make some of those
layouts happen.
So just that one caveat.
But aside from that
give it a try.
I'd love to hear
some feedback.
SETH LADD: Well, Dart is
certainly looking at helping
developers from all different
platforms--
non-endemic web developers, that
is, to be successful and
develop really high
performance,
full-featured apps.
And I think that implies
a strong, easy to use,
client-side, MVC-type
framework.
And that's where I think
Buckshot fits in.
So Adam, I need to ask, you've
been around in the Dart
community for quite a while And
you always seem to be able
to pick out all those commits,
almost right when they happen.
Tell me how do you do that?
ADAM SMITH: Late nights.
I signed up, I get the emails
from the issue tracker.
And I just kind of scan through
just the commit title.
And usually there's enough
description to find out if
there's something interesting
in that commit.
And a lot of the hot things like
finding out when mirrors
are gonna come, or what the
mirror API is gonna look like,
or what the change is, what
isolates are coming.
They kind of just pop out
in those commit logs.
Once I see them, I like to share
them with everyone else.
Because going through the amount
of commits that go into
Dart is so much, it's really
hard for everyone in the
community to keep up with it.
So I pull them out and I post
them on G+ because I feel like
the general community wants
to see some of those.
Even though they're all really
good commits, you just can't
go through all of them.
SETH LADD: Yeah, well
we definitely
appreciate the service.
You're right.
There's a tremendous
amount of commits.
And for those who don't
know, Dart is
an open source project.
So you can follow along in our
master subversion repository.
And then we have mirrors over
into GitHub there as well.
So if reading commits all
day isn't your thing,
follow Adam on G+.
And yeah, he does seem to pick
out the gems, the new
interesting things,
like mirrors for
reflection, and isolates.
This is all good stuff.
And I know a lot of us are
waiting with bated breath for
these things to land.
So thanks for that, Adam.
While we're chatting with you,
so you participated in the
Mountain View Dart Hackathon.
And you built a Redis
database driver and
kind of a front end.
Tell us a little bit about
what you built and
what did you learn?
ADAM SMITH: Yeah.
It was really fun.
We were a team of five people.
And I was kind of helping lead
the team because I had the
experience with Dart.
The other developers came from
backgrounds of Java,
JavaScript, I think Python.
And they really just picked
up Dart right away.
So in this project it was to
do an implementation of a
front end and back end in Dart
using Redis as your key value
store and then using some nice
features of HTML5 and CSS as
your front end.
So the front end would run
Dart and it would be this
virtual Linux terminal.
And you would send commands in
the terminal, but it's really
just a web browser with
a text input and
some really nice CSS.
And do an XHR request out to a
Dart server that runs on local
host through the Dart VM.
And then take those and then
proxy the commands to the
Redis service.
Which the Redis service ran
over a raw socket--
well, you know, a TCP
socket with its own
type of binary format.
A very simple binary format,
but easy to use.
It was nice to see that you're
playing with raw sockets on
the server side, dealing with
binary communications between
a different service that's
written in native code or
written in something, and then
sending all that information
back up through the Dart
web server into
the Dart web client.
So it was a nice way to see
information pass from a user
all the way down to a system.
SETH LADD: And that's such an
excellent point that at first
it wasn't very clear.
And we're talking about
Dart as a language
targeting web maps.
But Dart does ship with a
virtual machine that you can
run right on the command line,
right on the server.
And so it's enabled a suite
of Dart apps now
running on the server.
You have Dart running
on the client.
And I know that for your
project, you're running both
Dart on the client
and the server.
Is that right?
What are some of the things you
had to build, open source,
library-wise, to make
that happen?
LARS TACKMANN: Basically, the
Amazon integration layer was
not completely done yet.
We are waiting for
a few things to
happen in the Dart VM.
But that was our main thing for
using Amazon DynamoDB and
S3, and SQL SQS, the
queue service.
So basically we just had
to get some [INAUDIBLE]
reporting to the VM, which
landed really, really quickly.
I think it was like
a week after.
So [INAUDIBLE] really cool,
but [INAUDIBLE].
And that's what we
[INAUDIBLE].
We're going to use it more as
soon as it lands in the VM.
JOHN EVANS: Yeah, I think as
Dart matures you're gonna see
a lot more end-to-end
solution sets.
Because that story of having
the same language on the
client server is really,
really strong.
I don't think that's really come
to the fore yet because
there isn't that whole
tie-through that's clean.
But, wow, it's going
to be great when
you have that, right?
Instead of having to have three
different tools, you can
just work in one code base
and make it happen in
from stem to stern.
I'm looking forward to it.
SETH LADD: That's definitely
part of the vision.
In fact, one of the use cases we
kick around here is, Can we
use the isolates abstraction
as the way to communicate
between client and server?
Much like you can use the
isolate abstraction to
communicate between--
like intra-application
communications.
Can you do inter-application
communication?
I think, not only can you use
the same language in two
different worlds, server
and client.
Can you use the same
abstractions between
client-client and
client server.
So, yeah, I'm hoping for that.
JOHN EVANS: I've heard Gilad
talk about that a couple of
times on his videos.
And that's a really
cool thing.
If we can make that happen
with isolates
that's going to be great.
SETH LADD: Yeah.
Well I think the semantics
basically work in posting
messages, waiting for
returns on ports.
But the thing that always comes
up in my mind is, I
think to really achieve this
vision of a more unified
environment and client server,
I think we need to do better
at unifying our libraries across
client and server.
I know that John McCutchan, this
is something that I think
you've been recently
thinking about in
terms of the byte arrays.
And can you talk a little bit
about the work you've done in
the Dart Vector Math library and
anything in terms of using
those byte arrays across client
and/or server, or both?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Sure.
So first off, I'll talk about
using them in the client and
the server.
The issue right now is that
there are two different types.
One is float 32 list,
and that's
available on the server.
And the other is float
32 array, and that
comes from Dart HTML.
The semantics of both of these
are practically identical.
So it's a little bit tricky to
ship a library right now where
you're using float 32 arrays
or float 32 list.
Because there is like a fence
dividing these two worlds.
So anything that can be done
to bring them together and
have a common subset that works
on both the server and
the browser would be
very beneficial.
Speaking to what I've been doing
with float 32 arrays
with Dart Vector Math.
Last weekend, I started doing
some benchmarking of Dart
Vector Math and comparing it
with a port of GL Matrix.js to
the Dart language.
I noticed immediately that there
was a huge performance
advantage towards Dart
Vector Math.
But it didn't actually make that
much sense when you start
to look into the code.
Because it's a four-by-four
matrix multiplication
operation, the code is
the same everywhere.
There's not a lot of
variation here.
And looking at the dis-assembly
you can see that
the VM right now doesn't inline
accesses to float 32
array elements.
I've heard back from some of the
VM engineers that it will
in the near future.
So that's great.
But there's another benefit to
using float 32 arrays versus
native Dart objects.
And that's what WebGL
expects--
uniform values to be passed
into it-- is as a float 32
array, not a native
Dart object.
SETH LADD: I think it's
important to reiterate that
it's very early days for
the whole project.
It's still in technology
preview, which means we're
changing stuff a lot.
I mean, as we were talking
earlier with Adam, keeping up
with everything.
And performance is definitely
one of those areas where we
know we have particular
areas in mind that
we're going to visit.
We know that there is further
research to do there.
And so the kind of early work
that you're doing, John,
really helps us get to
where we want to get.
But yeah, we definitely have
work to go to improve it.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Of course,
it's very, very early.
But following on to this work,
I also started work on a SIMD
operations library embedded
into the VM.
So this takes the float 32
arrays and uses the SIMD
instruction sets available
on the CPU.
And the code that I posted is
SSE, but it could work on
other platforms as well.
This is very fast and works very
nicely with the float 32
array abstraction available
in Dart.
SETH LADD: Cool.
We did see that patch,
and that's awesome.
It was really cool.
It sparked a lot of
discussions here.
And it certainly is a lot
of work to go there.
But we hope that the discussions
continue with
features like that, which move
us above and beyond what's
available in web programming
today.
So thanks for kicking
that off.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's
a lot of fun.
SETH LADD: Chris, I'd like to
hear more about the book that
you're writing.
I mean, Dart is so young and
changing all the time, how are
you compensating with that?
CHRIS BUCKETT: Yeah.
So what I'm sort of trying
to do with the book is--
although it's going through
and it's teaching
Dart as core concepts.
So you've got the classes,
you've got types, you've got
things that people who are
coming from C Sharp or Java
will be comfortable with.
But you've also got things
that people coming from
JavaScript might not be
comfortable with.
You've got the vice-versa,
as well.
The dynamic typing that Java and
C Sharp developers won't
necessarily be so comfortable
with, but JavaScript
developers will be
comfortable with.
And so it's sort of bringing
those two worlds together in
the form of Dart.
So although Dart is changing
and it has evolved over the
last few months, the core
concepts are all still the
same, in terms of the optional
typing, the class system, the
interfaces, so on
and so forth.
And so in terms of keeping the
book current while Dart is
changing is proving--
it's not easy.
But I think that I'm sort of
splitting it up nicely.
So we've got a client part of
the book, a server part of the
book, the core components
in terms of
classes and type systems.
It fully advocates the
single-page, application type
architecture, which Dart's
main use case
really is, I think.
It's designed for building
proper web applications as
opposed to interactive
websites.
Although there's nothing to
stop you using it for
interactive websites.
It's a great platform,
almost like the next
step from GWT Grid.
[INAUDIBLE]
to produce proper
line-of-business applications,
games, and anything
in between.
SETH LADD: Well, you mentioned
optional typing as one of
those new, kind of core concepts
to the language.
And I'd love to hear actually
from the panel about how you
were able to approach
optional typing.
Is it something that
clicked right away?
Is it something that took a
little while to feel around?
John Evans, let's just
start with you.
JOHN EVANS: It didn't click
right away to me.
But the good thing was,
there was a couple of
good videos out there.
And certainly the mailing
list really helped for
that type of stuff.
Coming from a strongly
statically typed language like
the .Net family, I didn't
understand the decoupling
there, at first.
But once you understand that
types are really just
annotations in Dart, everything
at the run time is
not semantically tied to that,
then you're OK with it.
Then you use it as a tool
in development cycle.
And so I use it to help me check
my mistakes, as John was
talking about earlier,
while I'm developing.
But when I feel comfortable with
the code and I have unit
tests behind that to back it up,
you can back all that out
and just keep your local methods
and operations very
clean and very succinct
by not using types.
So, yeah I think that a little
learning cycle, but once you
get through that--
And certainly there's plenty of
good information out there
of what optional typing
is, and so on.
So now I use it and I'm very
comfortable with it.
SETH LADD: I guess the question
is-- and I'll start
with you, Lars-- is, What's
the benefit of
optional static types?
Now that you've gotten your
head wrapped around
it, do you like it?
And does it buy you anything?
LARS TACKMANN: I really
liked it.
But also having done a bit of C
Sharp programing, it really
just reminds me of how
[INAUDIBLE] variables are used
in C Sharp, but in a
more loose manner.
So I think I caught up with
it fairly quickly.
And mostly in the [INAUDIBLE]
is just added for type
information, to get
tab completion,
and to catch errors.
But I think that it's almost
become so good that it
actually catches most of
those errors anyway.
And particularly if you run it
in check mode then most of the
time you can just move the
type, at least for the
variables you assign
immediately.
SETH LADD: And maybe, John
McCutchan or Adam, if you
remove those types and you
use var, what's the
advantage to you guys?
Or do you even do that?
ADAM SMITH: I do.
You know, when I'm doing
samples, I pretty much use the
types for the ID and the
tools to really tell me
what's going on.
And I jumped in it without
having my prior background
influence the way I
was doing things.
I'm like, I'm just going to do
things the way they say-- use
types, don't use types,
see how it works out.
And I found a lot of times
when I just want a code
through something really fast,
and I just want to get
something running right
away, I don't have
to worry about types.
I don't have to be concerned.
And then I can go back and do
unit tests or testing, or even
add types later as
I need them.
Or if it's something public
facing, it makes a lot of
sense to have types to just
show off what it does.
But it doesn't really
interfere in
your internal calls.
I just kind of said, let me go
with it and see what happens.
And I think with that approach,
I didn't feel like I
got burned in any way.
I didn't have any kind of
rigidosity against types or
not having types.
I just went with the flow.
And I really like it.
It kind of just makes sense,
if that's possible.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Adam, I think
you really hit the nail on the
head there.
I really like types for
public interfaces.
That's, to me, I think, one of
the biggest wins that you get
with Dart, is that you can
really advertise strictly what
your library's API is
going to accept.
And you also hit it on the head
when you said that you
can ignore types and
go really quickly.
I like that when I'm just
playing around, it doesn't
matter, I can just throw
var everywhere.
And then once I'm satisfied with
the code and I want to
really clean it up so that it's
consumable by other parts
of my application library,
that's when I start to really
annotate with types.
But in the public API, having
types there is excellent.
SETH LADD: I really, really
appreciate that when I'm
trying to port or work with old
JavaScript code that I've
written a long time ago.
And I'm usually in reading the
method to figure out just the
heck I was doing.
And just having the types is
such a fantastic benefit in
productivity, and really
maintenance.
And I think that that's the
real test of a platform or
language is--
most languages you can get
dirty, get something running,
without even really knowing
what you're doing, you get
some results.
But how quick is that transition
to maintenance?
And what's the experience
like when you're
in maintenance mode?
To me kind of separates the
languages into fun toy or
something I can actually
do something with.
And the tools of Dart, like
the editor, and then these
refactoring abilities, and then
the type annotation, at
least for me mean that when I'm
in that maintenance mode,
it's actually a decent
experience.
And it's something like,
I'm not afraid of going
back to that code.
So that I'm really happy with.
JOHN EVANS: Yeah, I would
second that, Seth.
You know, Buckshot is over
25,000 lines now.
And so when I go back
into something--
I'm writing something new.
Something that I wrote six
months ago, now I get warnings
in the editor if I've forgotten
my old API, even.
So that's a big help
on the maintenance
cycle, you're right.
LARS TACKMANN: Yeah man.
It's definitely also--
I've been developing large
scale, client-side web apps
for a number of years now.
And when you do a web app
in JavaScript, you can
definitely do that.
But it starts getting a pain
when you go above like 20,000
lines of code, or something
like that.
It's hard to refactor it.
And with Dart I have also
a lot of code and we are
constantly moving it around.
I don't mind doing
that at all.
And when you get a couple of
errors, and you fix it, then
you are back.
So it's a huge advantage.
So that's why I'm sprinkling
types all over--
SETH LADD: Yeah.
LARS TACKMANN: To get that.
SETH LADD: Cool.
Well, that's definitely
the vision.
Glad to hear it's working.
So here's the portion of the
show where I want to hear some
feedback from each one of you.
What is one or two things
that you'd like the
Dart team to know?
What are some requests
from you?
Because you're some of our most
prolific developers out
there, we can check out your
GitHub, so it's definitely
obvious you're active
on the mailing list.
I think you know very well what
it is you need to go to
even to that next level.
So maybe we'll start with Adam
here and we'll work around.
But is there anything that
you'd like to see next?
Maybe a suggestion to re-bump
in the priority list.
ADAM SMITH: Next I don't know.
But there's one thing
long term that I
think is very valuable.
And I think Microsoft has
really, really hit it on the
head with giving SDK samples--
like thousands of samples,
if you go into the
SDK developer kit.
They got samples
for everything.
I feel that's something that
really helps sell a platform
and a language, When an
enterprise engineer can come
and just take stuff right out
of the box and say, OK, this
is what I need.
Or, this is the direction
I go.
Or, what's the proper way.
I know that's a long
term thing.
But it's just something I really
hope that the Dart team
can take into consideration.
SETH LADD: That's a
great suggestion.
I think that will
come in time.
And I totally hear you.
We have some, in fact.
Devon from the editor team
just cleaned up the stock
samples that come
with the editor.
And there's a couple of samples
that aren't readily
faced in the editor.
So I think it's more
on our radar now.
And I think over time as things
settle down, I think
there's still some library work
to do, then we can go
full force on that.
But I agree, I think most
developers want the cut and
paste codebook-style thing.
And so, yeah, great idea.
ADAM SMITH: Immediately, though,
I think, mirrors is on
the mind of a lot of people.
That might provide the ability
for people to do even more
innovative stuff with Dart,
and more kind of
out of the box stuff.
SETH LADD: Absolutely.
OK, check plus one
for mirrors.
Chris?
CHRIS BUCKETT: Yeah.
Plus one for mirrors.
That's top of my list.
Seriously, after that what I'd
really like to see-- and I
think this is not necessarily
a blocker for people like us
using it, but I think it's a
block at the moment for people
using it for proper commercially
supported
applications--
is the language is still
fairly moving
around quite a lot.
And I think that although it's
is good to have people
building stuff with it early
on while the language is
moving cause it means you
guys get great feedback.
It also means that some people
are wary of taking on a
language that's so new and
still moving around.
Because it means that code they
write today might not
work in six months' time.
There's not really an
easy answer to that.
Go on.
SETH LADD: Go ahead, John.
JOHN EVANS: I was just saying
get it done faster, man,
that's what he's saying.
CHRIS BUCKETT: I think, like
going into maintenance mode.
We've got software that we
wrote five years ago.
And the customer's still asking
for changes on it.
And at the moment, I couldn't
say, yes we'll go and write
our next big project in Dart
with it as it is today.
But I know that in six months'
time, or a year's time, we'd
definitely say, Yeah go
and write it in Dart.
SETH LADD: Yeah.
CHRIS BUCKETT: For me, it
can't come soon enough.
But obviously you guys need that
process to go through to
get the feedback from us guys
picking up early on and
building with it.
SETH LADD: Yeah.
And I know that getting to some
sort of milestone for the
language, at least, so that the
implementations can catch
up and the books don't have
to be changed every week.
And once you have a language M1
event horizon, if you will,
then with those assumptions
I think you can move on to
second- and third-order type
problems in the system.
And so you can go into
the issue tracker--
for everyone at home-- you can
go into the issue tracker and
filter on, I think,
milestone M1.
And it'll give you a sense
of what made that cut.
Now I don't really know exactly
what M1 means, but I
believe it's a line in the sand
for things we're going to
attack sooner versus things
we're going to attack later.
But at least that idea of what's
in M1 is forming so you
can kind of follow along
at home with that.
So, yeah.
I think we do appreciate,
though, having this kind of
rare, possibly only, opportunity
to make backwards
breaking changes.
So that's just part
of the process.
And you see it all because
it's open source.
So it feels probably
extra painful.
CHRIS BUCKETT: It's really good
comparing this to, say, C
Sharp or other languages that
have been developed.
Because Dart had been released
to the community so early on
that people have actually been
able to get hands on, get
dirty with it, even while
breaking changes
are going on in there.
And it's great that Google
have done this.
ADAM SMITH: It's actually
very fun.
I enjoy it, I think it's
very exciting.
[OTHERS AGREE]
SETH LADD: Cool.
Appreciate that.
John, what do you
need us to do?
JOHN EVANS: Plus one
for mirrors.
SETH LADD: OK.
JOHN EVANS: So I think that in
order for me to build a truly
comprehensive web application,
I'm really looking forward to
that integration to the
Google API ecosystem.
I got to get OAuth, right?
I gotta get G+ and be able to
hook into those identities so
you can bring that into
your application.
Otherwise you're stuck
with really wonky
workarounds right now.
So I think that one is
probably getting--
the pressure for that will start
to build as Dart moves
towards M1, I think.
Because people need that in
order to build a fully
encompassed application.
I think the second
thing that--
For me, particularly working
in Buckshot, I'm obviously
working in Dart HTML a lot.
And I've seen that API mature
very well over the
last almost year now.
And I'd like to see,
obviously, more.
I mean, more standardization,
more
normalization across browsers.
That's going to be
very important.
And I know that's
a big challenge.
Because there's a lot of
nuance between browser
standards, even at the
very property level.
But if Dart can make that happen
and make building a web
application easier from
a cross-browser story
standpoint, it's really
gonna be a win.
Because that'll draw
people right away.
A lot of the JavaScript stuff
now, those libraries do that
for JavaScript developers.
And if Dart has that batteries
included, it's going to be a
really great story.
So I'm excited about that.
SETH LADD: I think that the team
is going to agree with
you on that.
I think it's a very real problem
that web developers
face today is, how do you
deal with vendor prefix
differences?
How do you deal with
implementation differences?
How do you deal with APIs
that may not even exist?
And sometimes, we may not be
able to do anything about it.
But I think in many of the
cases-- and as the poly-fill
culture of JavaScript has shown
us, there are a lot of
cases where you can write to a
standards compliant API shim,
and help cover over-- spackle
over-- some of those
differences.
And yeah, so that's
a real problem.
So why shouldn't Dart
help you solve that?
So yeah, great feedback.
John McCutchan.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: All right.
I've been taking some notes.
So unified binary data support
and some more--
not more, but different
abstractions
around binary data.
Right now we have arrays
of typed data.
But you might want to have a
ring buffer or some other
types of containers for
storing binary data.
SIMD operations on
float 32 arrays.
And then, something that's maybe
up for discussion, is
I'm starting to turn my
attention towards isolates and
hiding libraries that I'm
writing behind isolates.
And I have two main concerns.
And I may just be wrong
about this.
But I think I read somewhere on
the mailing list that there
won't be support for passing
an arbitrary Dart object
instance through one
isolate to another.
And I really hope that
that does happen.
I hope that any Dart object that
I can construct can be
sent over to another isolate.
That would make me
feel a lot more
comfortable with isolates.
And then passing ownership of
objects from one isolate to
another efficiently, if they're
on the same machine,
would be awesome.
SETH LADD: Right.
I think you're alluding to the
transferable typed arrays that
the WebGL spec has
helped introduce.
So I should probably say that
the isolates library is one of
the less refactored libraries
in the system.
I think that it's integral
to the Dart story.
And there's a lot of
potential there.
And I think we're trying to
get some of the more core
things working before we
re-attack isolates.
So I expect some more focus
on isolates in the future.
And so this is good
feedback for us.
But, yeah.
I don't think what you see with
isolates today is our
final vision by any means.
So maybe I can ask a
follow up for you.
And what is a use case or two
that is dictating some of
these isolate based requests?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So I'm working
right now on a graphics
library that I want to run
as a separate thread,
essentially.
I want all of the object calling
to be done away from
my main application.
So basically that means that
I need my game logic to
communicate back to the
rendering engine, which is
running in whatever the
isolate happens
to be running under.
And I don't want to be limited
by how complex of a message I
can send between the two.
And I want to maximize my
performance, maybe generating
a vertex buffer.
And I want to pass that over
to the rendering engine.
And I want to do that as
efficiently as possible.
SETH LADD: OK, good.
Good use cases.
We'll finish up with Lars, here,
who has maybe written
the most Dart code I've seen
outside of Google--
possibly even also
including Google.
What is something that you'd
like us to add that'd help you
be more productive?
LARS TACKMANN: What
I really miss is--
I don't know if it's a natural
language feature, but I really
miss some middleware.
I mean, not servlets,
but building a more
modern version of that.
There are a lot of tiny web
frameworks out there that
could be turned into that.
But I feel that in order to
really move on with the server
side of Dart, and to write
all that stuff--
OAuth integration, we
need some kind of--
I don't know if it should be
standardized, but there should
be definitely be a connect from
the [INAUDIBLE] and Dart.
I really need that.
In order to just move Dart
forward we need to have a hub
be more used.
SETH LADD: Yes.
LARS TACKMANN: I really like on
the C Sharp where they make
this, I think, a [INAUDIBLE]
versus this [INAUDIBLE]
with really, really nice
integration into Visual Studio.
That's the test framework
everybody's using.
And that is just a really neat
way for people who are not
just digging around like Adam.
And if we patch and if we did
have commits to see what's
going on, things like that
is going to be needed.
I'm also, of course, going
to give a plus--
or probably 100--
to mirrors, or something
like that.
And then maybe a way to port
like in C Sharp so it can hide
the fact that you using an
isolate as an [INAUDIBLE]
API.
SETH LADD: Well I think the good
news is that the mirrors
stuff sounds like it's a
resounding plus 100, plus 4.
So there's active work on
the mirrors going on.
So the mirrors is a little
tricky, because we want to
make sure we can still enable
intelligent tree shaking.
And the smallest amount of code
over the wire, even if
you have reflection going on.
So we've got to get
that API correct.
But there's active work there.
So that's good news.
So good to hear that unanimous
feedback on that.
And we should mention
Pub, as you did.
The package manager for Dart.
That's in the SDK today.
It has basic support for
Git-based repositories.
And we have nice, high hopes
for this system.
We think it will open the
floodgates to third-party
developers much like yourselves,
but others.
Standardize around the package
format, like what do some of
the directors look like?
I know Kevin Moore on the list
has done some work to try to
plant some seeds in what a Dart
package might look like.
So I'm personally very much
looking forward to that.
And you'll be able to do A pub
install, and it just pulls
down all the dependencies.
And you as authors of libraries
would be able to put
your packages up for
Pub to consume.
So that's cool.
That's already well underway.
So good news on that.
ADAM SMITH: So is Google
potentially planning to be
maybe a central authority for
some packages, or at least one
central authority for packages
from third parties?
SETH LADD: Yeah.
Part of the scope of the Pub
project is not only the
command line tools to help you
install and manage those
third-party dependencies, but
also provide a hosting service
for packages and their metadata
to ease and enable
discovery of packages.
You should be able to do
something like, Pub search
XML, and find John's XML
library, for instance.
So, yeah.
Certainly we won't
be the only one.
And hopefully the community
takes these ideas and goes
even further with them.
But yes.
We will help seed the
third-party package repository
with something running
and plugged into
the Pub tool by default.
Awesome, guys.
Well I'm going to wrap up with
a shout out to each one of
your projects again, because
you've done so much good work
for and with the
Dart community.
We highly, highly
appreciate it.
So if you want to follow along
with all the news, find Adam
Smith on GitHub and
follow him.
He will get you plugged in to
the late breaking patches.
Sometimes quicker than the
editor can do a build.
So that's awesome.
And Chris Buckett, thank
you very much, joining
us from the UK there.
And good luck with your book.
I believe it's getting
published by Manning?
CHRIS BUCKETT: That's
right, yeah.
10 chapters written,
5 more to go.
SETH LADD: And do you have
an expected publishing--
like when should we
approximately find the book?
CHRIS BUCKETT: It should be
out in paper January,
February next year.
It's available now as
an early access.
SETH LADD: Ah.
So people can check out
your book right now?
CHRIS BUCKETT: Yeah.
Manning.com
SETH LADD: All right.
Good.
And John, awesome work on the
recent screencasts you've been
doing on Buckshot and
the XML library.
I know modern web developers
like to talk in JSON, but
there's a whole ton of stuff out
there with XML, so happy
to see that come out
of the community.
So appreciate that.
And the website, again,
for Buckshot is what?
JOHN EVANS: It's on GitHub.
GitHub/prujohn/buckshot.
SETH LADD: OK.
P-R-U-J-O-H-N?
JOHN EVANS: J-O-H-N,
that's right.
SETH LADD: Awesome.
And there's even a try Buckshot,
you can do it right
in your browser.
And you can watch
the screencasts.
JOHN EVANS: Yes.
It's all there on the
GitHub homepage.
SETH LADD: Cool.
It's good to see those MVC
frameworks start to come out.
And John McCutchan.
Thank you so much for
the awesome low
level work in the VM.
And the SIMD patches kind of
plant those seeds as well.
And I hear hints of another
library you're working on.
And so I'm excited to see what
that's going to turn into.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Me, too.
And you can get Dart Vector
Math at my GitHub.
SETH LADD: And your GitHub is?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Just
John McCutchan.
SETH LADD: Ah, perfect.
Yes, mine is Seth Ladd, I
find that much easier.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH LADD: Awesome.
Well thanks everybody.
Yeah, this is going to go
up on YouTube, we'll
share it out again.
And the Dart team is absolutely
listening to your
feedback and so we really
appreciate it.
And so thanks for working so
early with this brand new web
programming language.
It sounds like you're having fun
and we hope to continue to
keep you guys productive
and happy.
[OVERLAPPING THANKS]
SETH LADD: We're signing out.
Have a good weekend.
And we'll see you next
episode of Dartisans.
[OVERLAPPING GOODBYES]